um thank you everyone I'm really really
honored to have the opportunity to come
in and talk to you today thank you too
Leah and everyone else for introduction
and the kind welcomes the title of my
talk is developing communities to
develop themselves and I'm going to talk
a little bit about why I chose those
particular words somewhat later but I
want to start out by saying thank you to
a number of people who maybe even who
many of whom haven't interacted with
that I haven't interacted directly but
who have served as inspiration for some
of the things I'm going to say either
through their actions through
challenging me through talking through
things all these people that that I that
I've learned from some of the things
that I'm going to talk about I'll start
out by saying that I'm going to briefly
describe a particular case that i have
based some of this on but that case is
is not really the universal case this is
it's the project that I i work on which
is Leah said can I just take a second
I'm feeling very nervous this morning
and I'm stumbling over my words so I'm
just going to take a moment okay alright
so the project that I work on is a
project called YT and that's what I
based a lot of the stuff that I'm going
to talk about on but that doesn't mean
that it's specific to that and so in
fact I'm not really going to spend a lot
of time describing that project at all
in fact I'm just going to give you sort
of an overview of what it is so that you
can have a context for the particular
situations that have guided the various
different things i'm going to say today
so YT which stands for yours truly is a
piece of software that's largely written
by people from academia in fact it's
largely written by the same people that
utilize it they're the same people that
need to get academic credit for it that
are building their careers of the things
they use it for and in some cases are
building their careers out of the things
that they develop inside it and in fact
what it does is it prot it has a couple
different stages in the way that it
thinks about data
there's the ingestion phase of data the
representation phase where you take
multiple different types of data and
then you represent them in the uniform
way the analysis phase where you apply
some sort of model to that data and then
finally the visualization phase and what
all of these different phases of the way
that we talk about data have in common
is that they require a substrate or a
super straight at the bows of community
in terms of the people that deal with
that section of the code with that
particular area that it that it touches
on and people that utilize that and in
fact without these different communities
of people each one of these components
would usually be regarded as a separate
project or separate piece of software
and so it started out having a handful
of non developer users I started writing
it when I was a graduate student and we
had a couple different non developer
users but for the most part everyone was
really a developer at the same time that
they were using that people were pushing
it forward to address concrete research
goals whether those goals were you know
to study the way that stars form in the
universe the way the galaxies formed the
way that things evolved over time or
even large-scale simulations over time
there was an increasing number of non
developer users in fact many drive by
developers people that would come by and
contribute a patch or contribute a
couple different lines of code or a
small module or something and for the
most part though people were still
developers and users at the same time
and we didn't have anyone that was a
developer that wasn't also applying the
code to their own careers to their own
necessary development of themselves of
what they wanted to get out of there
their lives everyone was using it with
the same sort of stakes in the game and
then finally we're now moving to an area
where we actually have a few non-user
developers there are people that are
developing it that don't actually rely
on the outcomes of it independent of it
for their own work so they're not
relying on the way that it operates or
they're not relying on its functionality
as a goal to say publish a paper they
relying on the implementation of that
functionality in and of itself so this
is where where I'm coming from but you
might be asking yourself what's the
point of all this so what I wanted to
talk about was really about sustaining
software right we want to figure out a
way that we can sustain the development
of software and that software comes from
a variety of different backgrounds it
has a variety of different purposes we
want to figure out a way that we can
continue to ensure that that software is
useful and productive and when I say
that that's kind of loaded because we're
actually if we think about it we don't
really need to care if we're caring
about the data analysis if we're caring
about the visualization if we're
carrying about the actual products that
we make out of something we also need to
focus on the fact that we're here for a
reason we need to sustain our ability to
conduct inquiry we need to sustain our
ability to ask questions of data to
learn something from data and in fact
more specifically we need to focus on
the notion of conducting inquiry via
software we need to ensure that our
needs are being met that are our social
needs are being met by technical
facilities and that leads to another
interesting question which is do we
actually need to sustain specific
software i just presented to you a case
where i was i have had a fair bit of
success in my career as a result of
writing a particular piece of software
and so it is in my vested interest to
ensure that that particular piece of
software continues and we may all find
ourselves in a case like that if you
develop a project which then gives you a
name in your community whether that
community is PI data or academia your
interests are then in sustaining that
particular project sort of right but in
fact we don't need to think about
sustaining particular pieces of software
we actually should be thinking more
about sustaining the people that use
that software the people that develop
that software their careers and the
future of the field as a whole whether
that field is some particular sub domain
of academics
which I recognize this is a mixed crowd
of academic and industry I was under the
impression that it would be like divided
like at a wedding with but that seems
not to be the case and so we think about
sustaining and we think about you know
all these different things but what
we're really getting that is we're
thinking about sustaining people and
making sure that people have a place in
the community that they can continue
their own inquiry and really that they
have a mechanism of self direction so I
want to back up for a second because
I've learned a lot about sustainability
from a variety of you know people that
that talked about this a lot and there
are a variety of different definitions
so sustainable I remember hearing an NSF
program officer once say that he often
asks his asked the people that he was
awarding software grants to what what
does sustainability mean to you and the
answers he got back actually we're very
different from what he thought
sustainability was because oftentimes
when people say that they're interested
in sustainability of a piece of software
you know the first response is really oh
well you know it means continuing to get
funded to work on that right and that's
not necessarily the same thing as
sustaining a piece of software to to
actually continue to exist so there are
a couple of different definitions things
like keeping up with bug reports if you
get a bug report if your software is
sustainable of course you respond to
that bug report or maybe it's adding new
features it's making you know new things
that it can do is that sustainability or
is it that it works on new hardware
architectures that when the new Knights
asterisk chip comes out that it will run
on that is it that people can continue
to learn how to use it is that what
sustainability means that that it
remains accessible to newcomers is it
that it grows new features I guess I
kind of said that already is it that it
produces the same results over time
because that's kind of a mixed blessing
sometimes or is it that it transitions
between people
is the mark of something that's
sustainable something that can move
between project leaders when someone
moves on or when the project moves on
without them or really is it that it
keeps getting funded so I like to think
about sustainability in terms of um
Donald's law so um bells law is
something that gets evoked in
high-performance computing so Leah
mention that I'm from ncsa which is the
National Center for supercomputing
applications at urbana-champaign it is
famous for among many other things ncsa
mosaic and I think I don't know if it's
where he'll 9000 was supposed to have
been born I probably not because it post
gates 2001 anyway ncsa focuses a lot
that there are there for a long time
they've had super computers that were
you know ranked very highly in the world
and so on bells law is sort of a monster
that gets invoked whenever you talk
about parallelism encodes the notion of
um dolls law is that if ten percent of
your your process is explicitly cereal
then that governs the total amount of
parallelism that you can get the total
amount of speed up that you can get in
an ideally parallel situation and it's
really just a a mechanism for
quantifying bottlenecks and so when we
talk about sustainability we can think
about when we talk about sustainability
and communities we can think about um
dolls law because it's a representation
of the bottle necking that can happen in
a community if you have all these
different parallel situations where many
many different people everywhere are
working on things but there's only one
gatekeeper that gatekeeper becomes the
bottleneck and that's not a sustainable
way because that puts pressure on the
gatekeeper it puts pressure on the
community and it limits the scalability
and in fact it leads to I like
alliterations but i must confess this is
really one of my my poorest alliterative
slides ever it leads to three real
challenges with project maintainer
and with software it leads to the
challenge of bit rot least the challenge
of burnout and the leads to the
challenge of boringness see it's that
third one that doesn't really work but I
think that that's true if you only have
one person that is maintaining something
or that is the bottleneck on it then
you're more likely to run into
situations where you have software that
bit rods you're more likely to run into
burnout burnout on community processes
burnout on code review burnout on doing
the things that maybe not everyone wants
to do and then you run into the problem
of boringness if you're focused on
sustaining a piece of software and that
sustainability is very narrow in its
definition then you run in the case that
maybe it's not always that much fun to
do so I want to step back for a second
and talk about different mechanisms and
impact of those mechanisms and for the
most part I'm going to talk about this
from the from the perspective of how we
think about projects that were involved
in how can we how can we ensure that our
processes for dealing with community are
impactful and they are just so for a
long time i talked about empowering your
users or your developers and so i also
just use the distinction there that that
i think is is very harmful between users
and developers but i want to focus on
this word empower so the word in power
it's it's actually really nice to say it
makes you makes you sound like you're
you're thinking about things from a you
know a noble perspective but i want to
to eliminate the usage of empower and so
I want to thank Raquel homes from improv
science which is an amazing organization
for suggesting a different way to think
about this when you talk about
empowering someone you are immediately
setting up a power dynamic if I empower
my users to do something that means that
somehow I have the magic wand that will
give unto them their ability to shape
their own destiny and that's nonsense
one should never aim in a community to
focus on a power dynamic like that and
to try to consciously set one up Raquel
suggested thinking about this in terms
of development you want to enable people
to develop themselves and to develop
their own direction and sense of self
inquiry and that's not something that
you can give to them that's something
that you have to that you can enable
it's something that as you're designing
the social and technical systems that
you can foster and allow for but it's
not something that you can give and I
wanted to step back even more and talk
about voice so the voice that we give to
our communities and again i just said
give which is just going against what i
just said to do but the the voice that
one tries to foster in a community is
really the voice for oneself so I'm
going to quote Sofia on this because I
saw this on Twitter I guess this was
it's the 28th now so this was a little
bit over a week ago and I saw this and I
thought this was absolutely the most
profound thing that I had I had read on
twitter in a considerable amount of time
although I must confess that like
yesterday or the day before somebody
tweeted a picture of the guy that wrote
the Trump health letter next to a
picture of the dude from the big
lebowski and I thought that was also
really I thought this was absolutely
just moving and brilliant because asking
because asking people not to use
products is unacceptable and the second
half here only someone who has an
enormous voice would ask others not to
use theirs and I think that this touches
on so many different aspects of
community and sustainability because it
talks about the way that we interact
with people and the way that we interact
with the people that utilize our
projects that we interact that we we
maybe review code from that we try to
foster discussions between and it speaks
about our core values when I think about
community I think about how can we
increase the diversity of community and
there are a lot of different axes along
which this diversity can be measured
or not that not that we need to measure
anyway there are many different axes how
can we foster careers and how can we
lower barriers how can we lower barriers
to entry for people to gain leadership
positions in a project how can we lower
barrier to entries for people to acquire
self-determination in their projects how
can we lower barriers to utilization and
usage of software to the inquiry that
comes out of that and how can we foster
people's ability to direct their own
career and their own lives and this
brings back to the notion of what are
our core values when we develop a piece
of software embedded in that software
embedded in the way that we regard it
from a community perspective the way
that we develop it from a technical
perspective and the way that we
presented to others are the core values
that we all have so we can think about
breaking these up and this is just to of
an n-dimensional space along the the
ideas of technically easy versus
technically challenging and socially
easy versus socially challenging so when
I think about adding a new feature to
say YT I can think about the idea that
this is from a technical perspective you
know it's not so hard actually to go
ahead and implement this thing that rips
out all these different pieces of
software and then you know makes
people's lives much more difficult but
that's not socially easy in fact that's
socially challenging and it's
detrimental to the community there might
be something that's technically very
challenging but that people are all on
board with and so in particular when we
talk about infrastructure projects
oftentimes the technically easy and the
technically challenging and the socially
challenging the socially easy axes are
are much easier to separate out so if we
think about this more from a value
perspective the technically easy versus
the technically challenging we can think
of its functional versus problematic and
the socially easy versus the socially
challenging as detrimental versus
humanitarian when we make a change to
something we're impacting people's lives
when we make a change inside the
community we're impacting people's lives
we're impacting their ability to do
their jobs to find their way and so on
and so forth and I think sometimes the
way that this breaks down is the idea of
a product versus a project so this is
something that that I've struggled with
is the notion of a product and in a
product you've got some group of people
and they're making something and it goes
out they've productize that they they
send it outward whereas with a project
there's a bi-directional flow it's
really that the people that are working
on it maybe there are people that work
on it full time sure but there are
people outside of that group that have a
say in it that are stakeholders in it
and that can have some sort of voice in
the community and in fact I like to
think about this as a product being the
thing and a project being the people so
you might have a project that you know
puts out a piece of software but
everybody that utilizes that feels as
though they have a voice and a mechanism
for directing the direction of that
project and I like to think about this
as splitting up along the detrimental in
the humanitarian the reason that I'm
highlighting this is because early-stage
researchers early stage careers are the
ones that are the most likely to be
damaged in the case of a product that
suddenly changes directions if for
instance I've built all of my inquiry
all of my all of my utilization around
something that then disappeared I'm the
one that would be damaged by that even
though it might open up a new venue for
for the product itself actually in this
example i guess i used the first-person
pronoun but the example is supposed to
be an early stage researcher and i guess
i'm not that so anyway there are couple
different ways that we see projects
getting funded right or the way that we
see projects operating in the funded
model where you've got say money coming
into something
and then it dumps that project outward a
product eyes model where really you've
got you know things that are
interoperable where you've got people
downstream that are paying for it and
then a volunteer model where you have
perhaps a group of India pointed at the
right side where you've got a group of
individuals that are contributing back
upstream but I want to ask is productize
synonymous with self-sufficient I think
the answer is no but I think I want to
focus more on this notion of volunteer
efforts a lot of us operate in a
volunteer space where we're all putting
in little bits of our time on various
different things and I really want to
highlight and I apologize that I didn't
make the text bigger ash Dryden has a
blog called blog post called the ethics
of unpaid labor and the OSS community if
you haven't read this it's a masterwork
its outstanding because it breaks down
the way the volunteer organizations in
open source software by their very
nature systematically discriminate
against underrepresented and minority
groups simply by relying on volunteer
labor so when you have unpaid labor that
say you're making your work off of where
you're taking a little bit of time from
a variety of different people that in
and of itself is not an equal platform
particularly if you then expect that
platform to be how how individuals make
their name in a community if I only
judge you based on your spare time work
that you can put out there then I am
already cutting off segments of the
population that aren't able to devote
that spare time so let's return for a
moment to voice so when we think about
voice we can think about different ways
of deal of of interacting with a voice
we think about the different things that
either help or harm people to have a
voice in a community around software
there are barriers to entry for people
in different communities and the way
that we set up our technical structures
as well as the way that we set up our
social structures
actually either increase or decrease
those barriers there are different
methods and modes of engagement whether
those modes of engagement are you know
in person or online and there are
different methods of investment these
are all different things that we have to
to understand come together to form the
way that a person's voice is shaped in a
community whether that that voice is
shaped by having very low barriers to
entry to that community or whether it's
because a person doesn't have as much in
gate ability to engage with the
community as others do or whether it's
because people have different levels of
investment in a community so I might
have a very very deep investment in
something because say I've you know
let's say that I've made my name off of
it that leads me then to have a
different mechanism of engagement that
needs to be addressed in the way that we
set up our structures for engagement and
communication there are some very simple
things one can do be very welcoming very
respectful very professional in a
particular these can be very difficult
occasionally in in some communities to
to understand and recognize but I think
the biggest one particularly when we
talk about open source software is the
credit is not a zero-sum game this is
something that that isn't always obvious
if I stand up here and I give credit to
other people that doesn't necessarily
reduce my ability to then get credit
about it and this is something that you
know perhaps again having the academia
and the industry separated would help
because then I would turn towards
academia and I would say when you give
credit to someone else that doesn't
reduce your ability to get your next job
it doesn't mean that you're giving away
your intellectual stake in something so
this is something someone said to me a
while back which is a like it or not and
and I do want to emphasize that the
project that I work on is from a
relatively small community so like it or
not people look to you when they think
of the project as such it falls on you
to make it clear that we are not just
helping you you know what people think
every time you say we did this and this
is something that that can be a little
bit difficult
because it means that when you talk
about a project you're talking about the
community around that project when
you're talking about the work that you
did you need to make it explicitly clear
that not only are people contributing
and participating but that that
contribution doesn't always come out
through a github commit list because
code is not everything there was a
request for commits podcast episode that
was just released so Nadia egg ball has
a and someone else have a whose name has
slipped my mind have a podcast and this
week they interviewed about non-code
contributions and I think this is
something that happens a lot but the
perceptions in the community are
shifting code is not everything and so
when we focus on code contributions we
are explicitly undervaluing all the non
code contributions people that organize
things like PI data people that write
documentation people that participate on
a mailing list to participate on Stack
Overflow code is not the only mechanism
by which people can engage with the
community and it's certainly not the
only mechanism by which people should be
judged in that community and this can
lead to a couple different failure modes
people who have different levels of
engagement people who are always asking
why wasn't I informed and it leads to
this balance between innovation and
stability so I realized I'm running a
little short on time because I think I
was supposed to end in it's like a
minute or two so I'm going to end with a
a hobbyhorse that I have which is the
word scale so as i mentioned i come from
a place that does a lot with
supercomputing applications and
oftentimes scale is is very very
important to parallelism in encodes so
this is a plot that was made by a
collaborator of mine Sam skillman and I
like to show this in in a lot of my
talks although maybe don't anyway this
is a plot of
the largest particle simulations that
have been run on supercomputers over
time and so you can see that there is
you know roughly a logarithmic or
there's a power law that that increases
over time and around some of these you
can see a citation count we've only
highlighted the citation counts over 100
so that the point of this plot is really
that if you take citation count as a
measure of the impact of something that
doesn't always seem to be correlated
with the direct scalability of it the
impact is not always the same as the
scale I think in the data community this
will ring true and in fact if we break
this down as of March 2014 Mike Warren
broke all this down the cost of a GPU
flop was about eight times ten to the
minus eighteen dollars which is really
low whereas things like reading via
FedEx is about four times ten to the
minus twelve dollars storing something
permanently is about 10 to the minus ten
dollars for a 4-byte float a photograph
costs about four times ten to the minus
five dollars per four byte float human
labor for one second it's about 10 to
the minus three dollars and according to
most estimates of how efficient people
are at writing software one line of
software costs about ten dollars and so
when we talk about scalability and we
think about the impact of that
scalability it's clear software is the
most important part of this and so when
we design parallel ISM when we design
projects that are meant to conduct data
inquiry we need to think about the costs
involved the optimization costs and the
barriers that optimization put up to the
development in other individuals their
ability to utilize something
so I don't like to think about scale in
terms of particle number process or
number anything like that I'd like to
think about it in terms of nodes in a
network so if you've got two nodes in
the network that's great those two nodes
can talk to each other just fine if you
add three nodes the value of the network
starts to go up in fact it starts to go
up as N squared in fact as you start to
add more nodes in a network each one can
talk to every single other one and so
instead of having a value of n you have
a value of N squared because they're N
squared edges in that Network so this is
Metcalfe's law it was originally you
know designed it was originally to talk
about the value of the internet as it
was growing but I don't think that when
we're in a situation like PI data that
we should think about it in terms of a
network we're talking about that in
terms of people one of the coolest
things about PI data is that it brings
people together and this is the true
scalability that that we can deal that
we can see in our conversations here and
elsewhere the scalability between people
I think that's one of the most valuable
things for a conference like PI data and
organization like numb focus because we
can bring people together so numb focus
is a 501 C 3 that's designed to support
open-source scientific or scholarly
really software and education and all
these different things and I think that
the most valuable thing that num focus
can do is is bring people together in
particularly through conferences like
this where the different people from
backgrounds from careers from attitudes
all coming together to talk about data
and how data interacts with our lives so
I want to say thank you particularly on
this low energy sunday morning for
coming to 2 pi data early enough to hear
me speak and I also want to make sure
that I think again all the people that
that have inspired me through this talk
so thank you very much
it's okay if there aren't any oh there's
one be a hard one
mm-hmm
so what I would oh yeah actually yeah
I'm sorry about that that's that's
something that I've been trying to do is
to repeat the question the question was
on a technical level how do we how does
one implement things like this how do
you you deal with the person that's
that's contributed a couple lines of
code for instance and so what I can
actually say is that I'm certainly able
to tell you a whole bunch of different
ways that I failed so or that the
project has failed to do so but I think
that some of the best practices are the
ones that you see in successful
communities like Jupiter like like
interact like pandas and so on where you
provide clear mechanisms for
contributing feedback where you provide
clear mechanisms for distributing credit
to different authors and where you
provide clear mechanisms for people to
and and I have to be very I want to
construct this carefully for people to
advertise their own contributions so I
could stand up here and and say all
these different people that are doing
something but I think that one of the
more the most effective things that one
can do is allow other people to have a
platform to describe their own
accomplishments or two to put that into
the into the culture of a project if the
culture of a project is that there's one
person that gives talks about it all the
time that culture doesn't really
contribute to distributing credit if the
culture of a project is that there are
many people that are peers that can
describe something so I saw a tweet
yesterday by Matt Rockland from desk
about how happy he was that there were
three simultaneous desk talks going on
none of which had his involvement and
that's exactly the type of culture that
promotes a distribution of credit is the
culture that it's not bottlenecked on
what oh whoa i just got cut off it must
be said something unpopular it's not
bottlenecked on one person that that can
all wait contributions
ok
especially for people that okay so the
question was is there are there any
examples for balancing the social versus
technical aspects especially for people
that don't have access to fancy
supercomputers so i should note that i
don't currently have access to any fancy
supercomputers but i think there are
some really good examples if you look at
so what i would recommend is i would
recommend looking at things like the
wispy conference which is wsss PE it was
chosen because it's a Google singleton
there have been a variety of different
practices and papers that have come out
of that that described successes and
less commonly but occasionally failures
for distribute for balancing social and
technical issues and then also the
software sustainability Institute from
the UK which is that software AC UK
which describes also a number of
different social technical balances for
or things like that and you'll take you
out a follow up I'm sorry no okay
oh yeah oh so leah is so I'm being asked
to talk about the grant from the sloan
foundation so we have a grant from the
sloan foundation to numb focus to
investigate sustainability particularly
through partnerships between open source
projects and industry so a lot of this
was and I thank Leah very much for
forgiving me the for sharing credit with
me on that but a lot of this was was
developed by Tracy teal who some of you
may know from from deep among other
things the of how do we develop
sustainable business models for open
source projects that build upon or
partner with industrial best practices
so if you have a project what are the
the what are the best practices that you
can build on what are the recipes the
specific tools that you can utilize to
build out sustainability plans for that
project and so we're currently looking
for work currently in the process of
receiving job applications for a
projects director at num focus which I
would highlight its i believe the top
blog posts still on the num focus blog
is the job posting and so if you are
interested in issues of sustainability
for industry and open source
partnerships particularly when it comes
to software that's designed for
scholarly or scientific purposes i would
highly recommend that you investigate
this opportunity but we're going to be
putting out a best practices kit which
we originally came up with a backronym
for oh snap kit but we were encouraged
to change that anyway so the oh snap kit
is going to come out and and the notion
behind that is that it's a handbook of
best practices particularly when it
applies to sustainability of open source
projects in an industrial fashion so you
look at the way that industry sustains
their open source are there things that
we can learn like should all open source
projects using CRM that's a thing right
yeah should all open source projects be
using CRM should they be you know
engaging in this manner and are there
actual partnerships that we can develop
for industrial applications that utilize
open source
so I would highly recommend checking
that out the blog thank you again